hi I'm welcome to episode number 34 or
the weekly Google Plus on podcast I am
Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark
how are you doing I'm good then francisc
how are you doing I'm very very good I'm
very happy and excited about our guest
today
yeah hammer leaf from our team yeah yet
another one of our team members always I
always really enjoyed talking to our
team members because we have a great
team
he's always fun we have very very
different backgrounds and he's always
fun to talk to someone that you've known
a little bit enough something she
started styling she starts telling you
about yeah fires in data centers yeah
all sorts of fun stuff yeah it's a very
very interesting interview and at the
end of this interview actually we maybe
we should say we're gonna be talking
about we're gonna be talking about
monitoring yet on the cloud and
specifically Google cloud platform using
stackdriver yes and after that we'll
have a question of the week which is
about data management across different
repositories so what do you do if you
have some data in your machine some data
and Google Plus storage and some of it
changes you wanna update it you want to
keep it synced what are the solutions
how do you do that yeah but before that
we have the cool thing of the week which
is very very cool today yes so the cool
thing of the week is that kubernetes 1.3
was released yep
it is out and it is already available in
the kubernetes peach and very very soon
on GK it's got some really cool features
that have come along a long way
kubernetes 1.3 has some great stuff
there is more work happening on jobs and
stuff that's already in existence within
communities but also we're seeing things
like cluster Federation so being able to
do manage clusters across regions and
providers which is super super super
cool we're gonna have a link to a slide
deck that one of our team members
extended team members Carter Morgan I I
call him team member I think that's fair
he's a he's a super cool guy and very
very smart and does a lot of stuff with
communities he has a slide deck that
covers certain the new features in
communities 1.3
but yeah as you said before it's
available on gke and when we say
available it's it's rolling out over the
next week or so yeah if you've got new
projects it's probably gonna come to you
maybe a little sooner or maybe not but
it'll it'll get there it'll get there
yeah yeah soon and so we often talk
about oh yeah like cool new things and
kubernetes and things like that but I
think it's important to remember that if
you're interested on learning the basics
of kubernetes this discourse Udacity
with Carter and Cara Morgan and Kelsey
Hightower which is a great way to learn
the basics of kubernetes if you're crazy
about it we'll have the show notes we'll
have the link on the show notes
absolutely cool cool so why don't we go
and have a chat with agile let's do that
so I'm very happy to welcome at ahem
early from our team to the Google Club
from podcast hey how are you doing hey
guys I'm doing great I'm really excited
to be on the podcast this week yeah
we're very excited you're here why don't
you tell us a little bit about you we
know you're a little bit already but our
listen is done who are you
so I'm watching I'm really I'm a
developer advocate on the Google cloud
team and I focused primarily on
monitoring logging trace debug all the
things that help you out when stuff
comes wrong on your website but before I
came to Google I had a large variety of
jobs I was a developer I was a tester I
was a release manager at companies that
varied in size from a really early stage
startup that I stayed with until they
got to meet they got profitable or close
to profitable and I also worked at big
companies and little companies is in the
contractor and so that's kind of why I
come and work on the stuff dealing with
when things go wrong because I have been
there I've held that pager I've had that
midnight phone call saying wait wait the
site's down and I'm really passionate
about finding ways that other people
don't get that phone call that's such a
good person yep
that doesn't really that doesn't really
sound fun so why don't you tell us you
say that you are one of the people on
the team that specializes in monitoring
and things like this what is monitoring
so I'm sure that many of your listeners
have been there where they've got a
website or they've got some sort of
cloud-based or even locally based
application the
running and they need to know when bad
things happen because we all know that
computers are not actually perfect all
the time
discs go bad and discs fill up we as
software developers write bugs I have
certainly written my fair share and we
need to know when that stuff is
happening because it has the ability to
take down our site and pretty much
anyone doesn't want their site to go
down without them at least knowing ahead
of time preferably them doing it on
purpose because down sites that go down
or workloads that stop running usually
mean lost money and monitoring is the
way that we keep track of how the
resources how the application is
behaving so that we can have a high
level picture that everything is okay a
lot of the places I've worked have had
some sort of monitoring dashboard that's
mounted up on a screen that's available
to everyone so that everyone can kind of
have a high level picture that yes
everything is ok and that things are
going well or no everything isn't you
can see the trends and you can deal with
it before something actually takes the
site down and monitoring is also the
kind of thing that if you're one of
those people who used to carry a pager
still carries a pager or your team
passes around an on-call phone or maybe
you've upgraded to you know the current
decade and you have a system that
changes who's on call and just calls
your personal phone those kinds of
alerts are also triggered by monitoring
hopefully those alerts happen when
something is bad enough that it needs
urgent attention
but hopefully not bad enough that the
site is already down and I have been
there and I have carried that pager and
I actually still have kind of a negative
visceral reaction to a specific ringtone
for a specific brand of phone because
that was the sound that our on-call
phone made and it always meant that
whatever I was doing was gonna have to
be put aside so like if I was out to
dinner with people I was gonna have to
sit there pull out the laptop and you
know reboot servers from the dinner
table and I've done it
Wow so yep yep I have similar visceral
reactions to certain noises but so
that's really cool I mean I think that's
it's worth making the point like
monitoring it's both preventive as well
as incident based that be a fair
summation yeah it is both in my world I
would really like it to be more prevent
preventative than incident based but
computers are computers and I've been on
the on-call team or the ops team through
two data center fires now so
sometimes you just can't be preventative
out of curiosity when you say datacenter
fire is it a literal literal fire yes
both of them one company that I worked
at our data center the auxiliary power
units caught fire the whole datacenter
went down and they actually emailed when
they finally got some of the stuff back
up they emailed all the people who were
hosted there a picture of the charred
auxiliary power unit that had taken down
a good hunk of the fire hunk of the
datacenter and then the other datacenter
fire we dealt with there was actually at
one of our vendors and it was over a
holiday weekend and so the fire
department got the fire out but they
couldn't actually go back in and certify
that they could turn the electricity
back on to the data center until after
the holiday weekend so one of our
vendors was entirely down for a four-day
weekend three-day weekend fun so so
monitoring will detect that but so my
question is I'm assuming it detects of
resources go completely away pretty
effectively yes yeah but what about what
is the kind of things that you monitor
like I understand that you monitored the
optimum machine and maybe you monitor
like if I come if a network is up or not
yeah do you monitor all the things so I
think about it if you've been around
tech for quad for a while are you
familiar with networking they talk about
layers of networking and I actually
think about things as layers of
monitoring so at the base layer I
monitor to make sure that the resources
that I expect to be up in terms of VMs
or physical machines are up they are on
or are they're responding to just
low-level ping I also monitor things
like CPU usage memory usage and disk
usage disk usage is one that has burned
me enough times that I always keep a
really good eye on it because if you end
up with a bug that ends up spewing a
bunch of stuff to your logs you can
actually fill up your disk and the
applications I generally work with have
been rails and node and neither of those
deals too well with not being able to
write logs at all so I monitor CPU disk
usage memory usage and I'm mostly
monitoring those things to make sure
that they stay about the same because if
they start doing something that looks
outside of what looks normal for them
it's usually an indication that I have a
software bug that I haven't protected
and then after the bay
level of monitoring system resources
sometimes I'll monitor load balancers
and network connections as well I then
start monitoring stuff in the
application layer and that's gonna
really depend on what your application
is because if you've got a app that's
primarily doing video transcoding the
things that you're interested in are
very different than the things that
someone who's got a web serving workload
is web serving workload they might be
interested in the number of 400 and 500
range errors that they get or they might
be interested in latency or they might
be interested that a certain endpoint is
getting most of the traffic or a certain
endpoint is getting a normal amount of
traffic because they want to know if
there's a problem in their application
logic or pipeline and so it really
depends on the workload what I end up
monitoring but I do try to monitor at
all layers cool so all right let's let's
talk about what monitoring is available
on Google cloud platform
we have this stuff called stack driver I
believe that it used to be a different
company yes doctor er was acquired by
Google and they've been working to
integrate their products seamlessly into
the existing Google cloud platform
console and it the integration is lovely
at this point I've really enjoyed as
someone who's used a lot of different
monitoring tools over the years how the
place where I create my VMs is the same
place that I can see my alerts I can see
a dashboard it's the same place that I
can see my logs it's the same place that
I can see error reports distilled it's
all one login and when I go talk to
folks about their ops stack or they're
monitoring stack most folks seem to have
four or five products now one of the
things I love about stack driver is that
it's one product that does all the
things with one login so figuring out
who needs permissions for what is
actually really straightforward when you
get a new employee you don't have to
give them an account to five different
services and specifically on the
monitoring sides doctor ever monitors
all of our Google cloud platform
resources it can monitor app engine it
can monitor compute engine it monitors
load balancers and it can also monitor
resources that are in AWS as well it's
cross cloud there's been a lot of push
in the industry and also some internally
at Google too that many of our products
now work across cloud another good
example of that is kubernetes which
works Cross cloud and kubernetes is
technically Google's product is an
open-source product it's another example
of how Google is really pushing for the
cross cloud support cool so alright
there probably could probably go through
all of the stackdriver features for
hours and hours on end but since we only
have about 20 or 30 minutes you wanna
give us some of your favorite features
of the stack driver monitoring and stuff
yeah so I'm gonna kind of go at
depending on what resources you're
monitoring I have different favorite
features so one of my favorite features
is for App Engine actually and that
latency monitoring is built-in I can say
I would like to monitor latency and I'd
like to get alerted when latency is over
this threshold or increases by this much
and the other thing I really like about
the latency monitoring for App Engine
that's built in is that you can monitor
at the 95 percent so you can say I want
95 percent of my requests to be at least
as fast you can monitor at the 5 percent
I don't you can say so if 5 percent of
my requests are slower than this that's
an alert or you can look at the average
and several of the apps that I've worked
on have had an endpoint that is like
really fast most the time under 100
milliseconds most of the time but
occasionally there's that edge case
through the code that's just gonna take
forever and you know it's gonna take
forever but it really drags down your
averages so the fact that I can make
those outliers go away on my monitoring
is wonderful because that means that I
don't get that page if we happen to get
some anomalous traffic and get a couple
extra things to the bad path a couple
times and sometimes you know you want to
fix that path but sometimes you look at
it you're like yeah that happens a
thousand times a day I don't care it's
not worth the dev effort to fix it so
that's one of my favorite features in
App Engine is the late is monitoring or
stock driver for App Engine is the
latency monitoring and then you can go
into compute engine and one of the
things I like about stock driver with
compute engine and I actually didn't
know this until I was setting up a demo
recently is that there's built-in
monitoring for a bunch of different
common tools like my sequel or Cassandra
or rabbitmq and sometimes the story is a
little bit weird and recommend folks go
look at the docs we will actually detect
that you're running my sequel on a given
compute engine instance and we do that
by looking at this instance name looking
at the processes that are running and
also looking at what ports are open and
we can turn on the monitoring for my
sequel automatically so
say oh you're running at my seagull
instance on this compute engine and the
my sequel metrics will magically be
available in your debt and your stock
driver dashboard and I hate to use magic
because it's all computers it's all done
with well written code but yeah any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic it was a
lovely surprise when I was setting up on
my sequel cluster and even if it isn't
automatically detected turning it on is
super easy you add a config file and you
restart stacked right at the stack
driver monitoring process and now you
have access to metrics such as inserts
and updates for my sequel for HTTP
Fernet nginx you have access to the HTTP
connections how many are waiting that
kind of thing the metrics that make
sense are available when you need them
but they're not cloud crowding your
dashboard out when they don't actually
make sense and so that intelligent
decision about which metrics to make
available is really really nice that's
really cool
yeah the other thing that I like is that
there's monitoring built in for Google
container engine as well so if you're
running a container engine cluster
there's a dashboard that you get just by
and this is in the free chair you can
just go to stock driver and you can see
monitoring of your container engine
resources both by containers and also by
the underlying VMs and that's awesome so
it sounds like there is a bunch of stuff
that's like out of the box ready to go
as long as you're using some cloud
product on on Google cloud platform and
we're just like yeah here you go
is there anywhere where you have to do
manual steps I think on GCE you have to
install an agent um depending on how you
started it up you may have to install
the agent you do have to install the
agent in AWS so if you're going to use
it there when I did it for a recent demo
it took me less than five minutes the
instructions are super clear and if
you're one of the people like most of
the folks I hang out with in DevOps
community who uses something like
ansible or chef or puppet to provision
and your VMs you can actually install
the agent in a very straightforward way
with those tools there's a cookbook for
it for chef for example and so if you
don't want to do it by hand doing it
automatically is really easy and it's
just a it's just another monitoring
agent I've used many many monitoring
services and they all pretty much have
this requirement but it doesn't take
long you curl down some code yet put it
in a directory and change the
permissions and start it up
really straightforward if you're if
you're in a world where you do that kind
of thing often cool so so it seems like
having the basic monitoring of your
applications regardless of the stack
that using is pretty easy what if you
want to have some specific metric that
only your application knows about how
how does stack driver handle those cases
so you can do custom metrics and that's
one of the things that I really like
because when I've done apps before we
frequently would sit down were like well
how do we know if everything's okay and
we would sit down over a table and come
up with a decision that you know these
five endpoints need to respond in less
than 100 milliseconds 95% of the time
and then we could build we would then
was doctor ever you could then build up
a metric for that or I worked on another
app where we did a bunch of video or a
bunch of image resizing as part of the
load and so we needed to know how well
the memory usage was on the machine and
we had a bar where if the memory usage
went beyond a certain amount that was
concerning because we had messed up the
image resizing process and was
stackdriver you can create custom
metrics you can also create custom
metrics that you actually report from
your application there's an API that you
can report into stackdriver
a metric that is interesting to you and
have that show up in your dashboard get
alerts based on that which is awesome
and all those are going to be app
specific that's one of the things that's
really hard about talking about the
cloud is there's so much that you can do
with it and everyone's workload is just
slightly different I know a lot about
web serving workloads where there are so
many cool things that people are doing
that aren't specifically web serving
data processing for example there might
be other metrics that you need to report
in on and that's something that you
could do with custom metrics as well
nice cool so right now if people want to
get using I've stack driver it's in beta
so it's currently free but there was a
recent announcement for what the pricing
structure is Joanna talked a little bit
about that it seems pretty straight
forward though yeah so the basic pricing
structure when it goes out of beta and
into general availability is there's
going to be a free tier and that's going
to provide you access to metrics traces
and error reports because we're talking
specifically today about monitoring with
stack driver is a much bigger product
than that there's a lot of other
features involved
and those are all going to be available
in your Google cloud platform dashboard
and you can get that free monitoring on
Google cloud platform resources so if
you're using App Engine if you're using
compute engine you'll be able to see
your metrics in real time on the
dashboard for free now we're gonna have
a premium tier that that will give you
your Amazon Web Services integration so
there's your cross cloud it's also going
to give you support if you need support
on your monitoring logging this is if
you want to get alerts so you want to be
notified notified by in slack or HipChat
or pager duty or by SMS all that's gonna
be part of the premium tier it also
gives you custom metrics and several
other features so the premium tier is
priced at $8 per monitored resource per
month and that's prorated hourly and
that's kind of the basics so eight
dollars a month per monitored resource
now the question a lot everyone asks is
a tool what the heck is a monitored
research resource and a second question
is how does that work if your auto
scaling so monitor resources are App
Engine instances compute engine
instances cloud sequel instances and
load balancers so basically everything
that can be mapped to a VM is going to
be an instance so when you scale up your
App Engine app you have more VMs that
are provisioned and then you scale it
back down and then the auto scaling is
there going to take a snapshot every
hour and they're gonna figure out how
many monitored resources you're using
every hour and they're gonna Pro rate
based on that so if you spin up a VM and
then spin it back down or you use a
bunch of different VMs over the month
we're gonna try to come up with a way to
smash those together bin pack them to
give you the pricing so you don't have
to worry about us charging you for every
single different instance that you spin
up so it should work in a logical way
for auto scaling groups you should pay
for a fraction of that eight dollars for
the fraction of the time of your scaled
up suite so if like I'm on App Engine
standard and I have a short spike where
it goes up a fair bit but then comes
back down relatively quickly sort of
mush is that all together into one big
chunk they don't have to worry and so
we're gonna and it's prorated hourly so
divide eight dollars by the number of
hours in the month and that's your
hourly rate it's really not that much at
all the other question people ask is
about how you how that works for
containers if you're running containers
on compute engine and if you're using
container
you are actually running your containers
on compute engine resources we're still
just gonna charge you for the compute
engine VMs and the amount of time
they're up so if you scale up your
containers but you don't actually scale
up the number of hosts that you're using
to run them you're still gonna be paying
the same price cool
that's very cool so we're kind of
running out of time but there's actually
a question that I would like to ask you
which is okay so I did not know
monitoring was a thing and I have
something running a production what do I
do
so what is the first thing I should
start doing like right now so here's
here's the thing that I tell folks when
I'm doing mentoring and I will say right
now that I am NOT an expert on DevOps
but the very first thing you do is you
should set up an uptime monitor and all
that's gonna do is it's going to I
usually set this up to hit a specific
URL frequently the base page of my app
and it tells me if that page stops
responding so it basically tells you if
that page is throwing a 500 or 404 if I
want to get a little more sophisticated
and stackdriver you can do this you can
have it check for a specific string of
text and I often do the company name in
the footer because almost everyone has
their company name and the copyright
info or their name and the copyright
info in the footer of their website and
if that stops showing up you know that
there's a problem with the basic
rendering of your page
protip don't use the date if your date
auto increments on the new year because
then you get a new year's day page when
the date auto increments so up in a year
but you know get your time monitor set
up then the next thing I think folks
should do is they should set up some
sort of metrics based on latency or
application errors on the things that
they know caused a bad time for their
customers and they should also set up
some basic metrics with stackdriver you
can do it based on trend so if your
memory usage increases by 200 percent
over 10 minutes that's the kind of trip
that's the kind of alert I would set up
on the system level because that means
you don't have to actually know what
your normal state is but you can still
get an alert if something weird starts
happening because the whole goal of
monitoring is to let you know that
something weird is happening so then you
can use your big human brain to try to
figure out what it is so really it's
about change it's not necessarily what
your base case is yeah that's that's
that that's the I have no idea about
monitoring and I would like to get in I
would like to
do this thing because it sounds good
stories focus on change and focus on
making sure that the basics of your site
is all right because the worst thing
that can happen is someone types in your
URL or clicks a link and search results
and ends up at a 400 or 500 now that
makes sense all right before we finish
up is there anything in particular that
you'd want to like mention or feature or
highlight or anything fun like that we
may have missed no I don't think so I
just think everyone should at least
since it's free right now
people should check out stackdriver try
it if they've got a cross cloud though
they should totally try it there and
they can see how awesome it is to have
their AWS and their GCP resources side
by side in their dashboard the example I
did for one of the talks I gave recently
was I did a my sequel cluster that was
half and GCP and half and AWS and I was
replicating from GCP to AWS and it was
really great to see the compute
resources that were being used memory
and disk and all that but also seeing
the inserts and the deletes and the
updates side by side for all of them and
I was able to set up the same alerts on
the same exact thresholds for both both
clouds and seeing that side-by-side as
someone who's done a combination of
cloud and on-premise uncrossed cloud as
part of disaster recovery and all that
it was really nice and it made me wish I
had these features back when I was
responsible for keeping a site up so I
think people wallets in beta should go
check it out see if it's gonna work for
them see what it looks like when all of
your monitoring logging error reporting
stuff is all in the same place and I
think that the the demo that you were
mentioning not only you gave a talk but
you also wrote it up there's a blog post
on the GCP blog called six things doctor
ever brings to the DevOps table and it's
awesome cool so we'll add that to the
show notes for shortly
all right great thank you so much for
joining us sure it was great talking to
you I learned a whole bunch about
muttering I didn't know before thanks
guys thank you thanks guys this was
really really fun that was a great
conversation that we have it I just
thanks so much for joining us today I
learned a whole lot about what's
possible and not possible with our
monitoring solutions yeah finally you
can detect if your data center is on
fire yeah I think that I think I want to
set up custom metrics with smoke
detectors so that they can send it to
stackdriver and then
yes there's a fire there's indeed a fire
an uptime check is not enough yeah yeah
we said the computer will not fix the
fire now
no absolutely all right so why don't we
get on to your question of the week I
think you had an interesting one there
yeah why don't I set it up for you okay
you can give me the answer so we're
talking about if say you've got a Google
Cloud Storage bucket and there's a bunch
of data in it and you're like okay I
want to pull this data down so I can
look at it so you pull it down using GS
util great that's fine and then you're
like oh wait there's some stuff I need
to change in it so it makes some small
changes to like maybe three or four out
of the 200 files or something like them
and then but I want to sync that up to
what's in the cloud but I'd rather not
send all that data straight back up I'd
rather just do we ever changed is there
a way I can do that absolutely and the
way I see it is not everybody knows this
command because it's it's a Linux
command and it is actually not that well
known really yeah I mean you have a
Linux laptop but not everybody that is
oh okay yeah but there's this command
called our sink that basically what it
will do is it will check the difference
between the the the contents of the
source and the content of the
destination and it will send only the
changes and not only that but it will
also do check sums to make sure that
everything that you're actually sending
will be correctly received so basically
it's a very safe safe way of sinking
back your changes to the original to
regional data store now it is important
to be careful because there's one thing
which is like the - so - D and actually
what I will do is will it will do
recursively and anything I've done this
which is if you like you know the
commands have source and destination yep
and source goes first and destination
goes after oh you don't flip those if
you flip those basically yeah you delete
all your data so you should be careful
with that - date as the delete now
that's the what it does is basically a
recursive so like directory so right
yeah so if you say oh I want to change
like everything that is
inside of this place with like this the
source that's the destination and you've
do it backwards yeah that's bad times so
you don't wanna do that and if you if
you want to understand better with
arcing does for me the way you see it is
kind of like get when you do get and you
don't get pull get push what you're
sending over the over the network is
just the difference between the files
that's exactly what we're doing so if
you have a huge state a huge data file
that lets say I don't know like 1
gigabyte and you only change the first
1k of the other image of a problem image
or a video whatever yep
you will only send that part I changed
so it will be much much faster than the
whole file backup so for those people
who are familiar with our sink is this
just using our sink or is this our sink
with some G clad tools how does that
yeah so so our thing is Linux command as
we're saying you could I guess use our
sink directly with Google Cloud storage
but you're gonna have to be dealing with
authentication and there are no really
sure good work so instead we have gsutil
our sink which is a sub command of
gsutil so you can simply say gsutil our
sink source this in a source source
directory which could be either your
local machine or somewhere in the cloud
eventually Google Cloud storage but
actually you can do it over multiple
clouds and then a destination which
again could be either local or something
remote and it will just do the same
between nice actually I'm just looking
you can also do it from between like
Google Cloud Storage and like an s3
bucket as well yeah absolutely so that
is pretty cool if you're thinking about
migrating or having two different things
that are up-to-date you could run this
record like every day at some sometimes
you just run this script and it just
updates everything together so it's it's
a very very handy tool if you have if
you need to sync things up our sink is
what you want it sounds very good
excellent well thank you very much for
joining us this week
I believe when this comes out you'll be
doing something special yeah so
last episode I I don't know how to use
calendars so time is hard time is just
very very different yeah is there even
time zone these weeks so yeah we're not
wigs weeks so yeah by the time this
episode comes out I will actually be at
gopher con I'm doing the opening keynote
and super excited about it yeah my
slides are they start to look good I
think that it's gonna be a good talk
I've seen some rehearsals pretty arrests
just one said just a little bit
impressed pretty excited about that so
yeah I will still be in gopher con and
actually on Wednesday we'll be running a
go project room so if you're around go
there go check it out we're gonna be
talking about the go project we even
have a little session on diversity we're
gonna be discussing what can we do to
make the goal community more welcoming
so if you want to go say hi come say hi
head on down and what about you so
unfortunately I won't be African doesn't
doesn't pan out for me this year I know
I think for me next will be in August I
will be app active in some capacity so
if you're gonna be there drop me a line
on Twitter or something like that you
know August oh my god you're not doing
anything till August I have some things
cooking nothing's been sort of locked
down yet it's we will announce we'll
work it out great
well thank you so much again for taking
the time to do this episode I really
enjoyed this one yeah me too thank you
so much and see you all next week see
you next week